good morning Millennials welcome to the
morning toast happy Monday it is a
gloomy rainy sad Monday here in New York
very sad maybe even sadder by the fact
that I look like a rat because it's it's
a first you know we're all about making
history here at the morning shows you
know we are the largest podcast in
Massachusetts and New Jersey you know
we're constantly beating the odds and
today is no different I am here for the
first time in history without both
makeup and hair like sometimes I like
come with like a literally the littlest
bit of makeup and like my hair is done
so like it makes it look better today
woke up super late
I'm so busy cuz I'm leaving for Israel
today like I had no time to hear about
the way that I like well you look really
young so that's something wow thank you
that's so kind
yeah so I guess that's the key to be to
staying young like look like a camper
who likes doesn't own makeup looks like
something you own makeup that I'm like
hating is like my paleness but I'm
hoping to fix that in Israel yes that
you can do it's an ugly day outside but
if you use my Jackie O float presets
which bunch this morning you can make it
a beautiful day we're all about the good
segues here I'm so excited about my
preset lunch I've been working so hard
on these bags oh my god she really has
like really didn't like playing with my
website and really making my presets
perfect I've been on the preset train
probably talking about down the show
since October um and then you know
presets in general especially blogger
presets are one really expensive out of
control you know ever since I started
buying Precepts I've been getting
targeted ads for like random bloggers
and there was a set that like really
spoke to me and they went on you're
gonna die ready how much it was to
presets for $70 that's so crazy when I
started in the preset game I didn't know
that there were so many options and it
was they do it for the toasters who told
me to try it see so I was able to get a
lot of presets affordably and like
figure out my vibe but when I first I
saw like one the most prevalent presets
were like three presets for $80 which is
just like so crazy so it's a setting
like it's crazy it's crazy and also more
than that like most blogger presets are
like very specific like vibe of like
orange and brown and like gritty and
like that's not me it's no but it's not
me me too so I've been like spending
last few months inadvertently making my
own presets for all of my photos and so
many people ask how I edit my photos and
I've decided to share them with the
masses so I have two packs of presets
each one has a set of pipe 5 presets
it's five for twenty-five dollars in
prize victoria's secret under
5:45 which is something that I've always
just been into and and and also like I
think that's enough like that's a
reasonable price for a preset and if we
really hard on them I think they're so
great ten total there are so many fun
ones my stagecoach presets my Coachella
presets my Theo presets he gets the most
compliments on his flow it's is one
called precious gem perfect it's part of
the in noir pack then I have really
specific presets so like instead of like
having arbitrary names they like do they
do specifically something so she's so
helpful in how am I supposed to remember
what like canvas midnight jeans you know
in my indoor pack I have a preset called
ugly indoor photos for like photos that
you think are unset must be the most
might be the most valuable I use that
one weekend and then I also have South
East because like most presets are
really made for the background to like
height in the background but what about
the woman or the man in front of the
camera so they're very specific which I
think makes it really helpful for you
know beginner pre setters I've had
natural light you know which would be
perfect for a great a day like today
totally well I you know I did get the
hook-up I got them a few days ago and
I've been using them so ever it should
get them to either premium but someone
who knows nothing about presets or like
how to use them I thought I found a
really helpful and simple and I made a
YouTube tutorial that's go to my
Instagram story it's all there for you
that teaches you how to use presets
because I was just like you six months
ago when was October it was just so ugly
with no Instagram fault yes I was just
like you six months ago like taking
premium content and then like not
knowing how to get it to the next level
you know there's something about presets
that really it turns you into like this
business person like you know know like
now my flow just gives me joy and I know
there are other people out there who
care about like dumb [__] like that - so
now jackieo flow calm you have this bow
flow F low-50s I can see the pictures
that you post using a preset oh yeah
that'll be interesting to see yeah I'm
excited just like for today but also
forever like just have my presets out
there making Instagram or premium please
right you're really contributing to the
world I think that I am well Jackie and
I had so much to discuss Game of Thrones
was on last night I'm heading to the
holiest land the motherland Israel
tonight and I just so much to do before
that so if it's all right with you
mm-hmm
it would be my honor and esteemed
privilege to just immediately
dive in to the fast five stories that
you need to know before you wake up and
take a bite out of your morning toast we
have some big stories a lot happened
this weekend and I think the one story
that's really shook the world I'm so
anxious the Internet to its core is the
James Charles saga and so people have
been asking us to recap and for a while
like when I first saw I'm in the morning
toast group for YouTube like aficionados
and it's the morning Tube okay
and they're always posting about like
YouTube drama I'm like I know like the
very basic and I've only recently become
like a big fan of James Charles used to
and I've just like been I subscribed him
and I've been watching his videos I
think he's like funny I love him he
talked so fast like he swallows his
words like makes us look like the
slowest people alive and I've just been
like really into like his Instagram and
his whatever and like the business
behind it cuz like then he had the
sister squad and like I love him a
Chamberlain like I was getting into it
like just starting to dip my toe into it
when all of this happened there's
YouTube drama like every single day so
it took a few days for me to really take
this drama seriously because roots like
it's very real like and also youtubers
get cancelled all of the time and then
they bounce back as they you know they
have their own companies and like they
don't rely on brand so much and they
have their subscribers so like just
because he was going through a
cancellation didn't mean that this was
like the nail in the coffin but
sometimes there's like huge
cancellations on YouTube and like people
in the real world never hear about it
right it has transmitted I had never
heard of tattoo Us / me neither but
because James Charles is like this
figure that people just like literally
despise they took on the life of its own
I took on a life of its own like he had
just gone to the Met Gala he was
reaching astronomic by the way it
couldn't have come at a worse time for
him no it really couldn't have so if
you're like but Ben was like can you
explain the YouTube drama to me and I'm
like I literally can't say enough to do
it on the toast tomorrow like it's just
too busy okay so like bare bones of what
started all of this talking Westbrook
making a 45 minute video you know
outlining how James Charles is just a
bad person I didn't know who taught you
Westbrook was but the vibe that I've
gotten is like she's like this very
respected old-school youtuber like who
has been in the beauty game forever and
like it's just like like not to be
messed with you know you might not know
her if you're like sixteen and a lot of
James Charles's fans might not know her
but her and James like we're very much
like very close friends family that she
helped him with so much her her and her
husband like did everything for James
when he was coming up and just like
really have been like a shoulder to cry
on
so she recently launched a beauty
supplement line called halo beauty like
a direct competitor of sugarbear hair
yeah and like my mic I'm gonna blow my
nose and all supplements that would
promote hair growth and wellness and
beauty and all of that and James has
been like one of her closest friends and
supporters and she's always supported
him and all of his endeavors and he
thereby should support her then I guess
at Coachella James found himself in an
unsafe situation that's when he says
she's like I know that this is a lie but
his this is use he says he found himself
in an unsafe situation like security
wise at Coachella and the brand
sugarbear hair was just there to save
the day you know with passes a house a
security guard and a contract you know
to work for them so in order to get all
those things he a few like a week and a
half later had to post about using sugar
bear hair and that's when taki Westbrook
snapped and it was it wasn't just that
specifically it was like that in
combination with a lot of other things
that he's done to her and her people
those things were basically just like
he's a kid who's gotten so rich and so
famous like overnight and it's really
affected him and his judgment and his
behavior and all of that wasn't enough
until the sugar bear thing that like she
took really personally especially cuz
she said her and him have had like
countless conversations about just like
I'm sugar bear hair it's like the worst
company and like he was like making fun
of every influencer partners but then I
guess he was making front of the crash
chance yeah so it's crazy he and also he
had said to her that he wouldn't promote
her supplements on his channel because
his subscribers are really young and it
would be like irresponsible to promote
supplements to the youth which actually
makes a good amount of sense but then
you're gonna promote sugar bear hair so
like he wasn't even supporting his
friend in the way that he could have
been and then he goes and supports her
competitor and like that was the final
straw for her catapulting her until I
just have to say in Cochella like having
been there if you get there like
something's not organized for you like
it's a dead zone like there's no way
you're gonna get in touch with a brand
or get in touch with passes and security
like it is the busiest weekend ever like
I don't care who you are like that just
is the fakest story I've ever heard
no it's definitely a fake story but even
if it's true like let's give him the
benefit of the doubt for one second like
that's not first of all you show up at
Hotel you have everything planned out
down to your assless chaps
right but you don't have a house or
security or somewhere to stay literally
have an assistant a manager an editor
like you have 400 people who work for
you and it's literally just their job to
make sure you different place
to place be like and everything's
organized only sugar bear hair can save
the day right like every brand in the
world does that Michelle and you choose
to partner with sugar we're here and
like they had the contract at the ready
right now like is there a printer so his
soy doesn't totally add up and so he's
like he was not over the story like
doesn't interest me at all no because
that was just the reasoning behind why
she uploaded this video which said so
much more than the sugar bear hair drama
and that stuff was not only more
interesting but a lot more incriminating
yeah so I will say it took me a few days
to really become interested in the saga
and as as two people who have been on
the other side of it I'm always quick to
say you know like let's lest we not just
be so quick to jump in and someone's
career like it always makes me sad like
the vigor behind which people are
excited for someone's career and I feel
like before we were quote-unquote
cancelled like I used to be like yeah
let's go come on follow and then now my
automatic instinct even if I don't know
like the story I'm like let's hear a
manatee round so before I even watched
Heidi's video I went to watch James's
video because I was ready to like take
his side and I like him I like what he's
done I think like he's awesome you know
yes there's a lot not to like about him
but in general like he's a good
businessman like he's a fantastic makeup
artist like he's changing the game like
here for it so I go to watch this video
and oh my god it was painful it's an
eight-minute video I couldn't get
through more than two minutes so I was
like and what's so crazy about it it's
like he not only was talking so slow but
for him it would be seriously if we
spoke like this and also like the
swallowing swallowing the check in the
fake right well like Jennifer your mom
like this so irrelevant as he brought up
his mom yeah that's just so then after
so I couldn't even get through the video
and I was like oh I need to know what
the allegations are so I went to the
talking video which is 45 minutes yet it
was it was quicker to get through than
James no and by the way I didn't know
her and I loved her she's so pretty so
well spoke and youtubers are always like
and it's like Asik like like like like
like like and she was just like this
well-spoken beautiful goddess right and
like she was coming from such a place of
love like even as she's swiftly ending
someone's career she can't stop saying
how much she loves you want to know why
she didn't make that video with the
purpose of ending his career
and I think maybe if she knew that it
would have turned into what a turn in do
you like maybe she wouldn't have done it
cuz she just doesn't give me that vibe
of like that type of person yes she was
making the video cuz I guess there are
all these like drama channels on YouTube
it's like TMZ and James was going to
them like giving them tea and like if
she if she got her message out in any
other way it would have been
misconstrued like she's bitter or
something so she just won in her own
words so it's out there for everyone to
hear I don't think she ever expected
this many people to hear it to the point
where James Charles has now lost almost
two million you know more how many so
what I checked he started at sixteen
point five okay million and when I
checked last night he was at thirteen
point nine so if he gets to thirteen
point five he's at thirteen point eight
now so two point seven million three
million that's a lot and she's gaining
off she went from five point eight to
like eight that's crazy I mean this is
millions of subscribers like that's a
lot that's big and that can affect your
you and your business in a huge way yeah
so many celebrities who I didn't even
realize followed James have unfollowed
him James Miley Cyrus Miley Shawn Mendes
yeah it can be said I know crazy really
crazy like he still does have like 13
million subscribers but like this is a
major major hit and it's like everyone
else even in the community and I guess
online it's just like just cheering it
on because I guess he really has just
been like such a horrible person to so
many people yeah it's like you okay so
it's like this is a different example
but it's like when someone gets accused
of sexual assault there's like always
four more people who come out and like
you never just sexually assault someone
once like yeah it's your thing so when
you're like so nasty to one person
there's like 400 other people who know
exactly because like you're not just
nasty to one person you're a mean person
right you know Jeffrey star has spoken
out and said that everything that Shante
said is true and that James is quote a
danger to society what's crazy about the
Jeffrey star of it all is James Charles
was they both subscribe to beauty guru
on YouTube but now that he saw so many
followers Jim Jeffries star is now the
top it got and now I'm like deep in the
YouTube community we were watching
jeopardy star videos all day yesterday
oh my god totally first of all so funny
like I did that he did this video about
face full of makeup brands that hate me
hysterical and then he also did this
closet which was out of control
the pink vault was out of control like
how does he have so much money
jeffree star cosmetics
from that yeah I think so I mean from
YouTube and being an influencer but then
also like owning his own cosmetics like
in the same sort of business model as
Kylie yeah crazy yeah Wow anyways it's
really been everywhere and it's and it's
not slowing down no not at all but you
know who I'm sure is just loving us
Olivia Jade because people are finally
talking about a new YouTube scandal
scandal that's made its way into the
mainstream yeah it's like it's no longer
about Olivia no I mean I I do feel badly
for him like I'm sure he's like you know
in a bad place you know what he made
that video but and he might have had
time no and also he made the video when
like everything was going on it was it
was heated and it's still what didn't
feel sincere or like sympathetic so that
was your chance it was a weird time
because well that's the thing he was in
the video he was working overtime so
hard to look sympathetic and genuine and
the fact that he couldn't even muster up
one wheelchair for his mom was telling
yeah it's like the timing of his video
was weird and wrong because of scandal
very much wasn't over it only got worse
from there because now there's like four
or five people who are on Twitter making
work legitimate acute accusations of
sexual assault so well yeah or like
sexual predatory behavior yeah so now I
don't know how one responds to that like
no one can cancel you like really like
just for being mean like but you know
what I mean yeah just really like a diva
or a bad guy or someone who got like two
big for his britches but like when
there's real criminal activity ya know
then it takes on a life of its own and
that's the sort of stuff that you know
brands are not down with have any brands
trapped in morphe has unfollowed him
okay and he has his james morphe palette
which everyone should probably go get
cuz it's gonna stop soon also I had no
clue that he was making so much money
yeah the beauty game is you gotta get
into it we've got to get our own
cosmetics line millions we need that
vault oh my god totally so we'll keep
you updated on this drama but it's it's
drama for sure it's trauma for sure I
really wanted to be on his side and talk
to us which just blew me away
like and what's weird about this whole
thing is that James just like actively
working right now I'm doing mean greets
and I just like can't help but think
like how awkward those mean greets are
oh my god no but he just gotta power
through and you have to keep working
because if he goes into a hole and never
seen from again like it's that's not the
move for him like it's just wonder if
people are as he lost true followers
like I'm sure he still has his stands
and those are the people who are going
to his mean greets anyway you don't wait
in line for a James Charles meeting
agree if you're the sort of person who's
ready to turn on him on a dime like yeah
even if all this stuff came out about
like Taylor Swift like you would still
show up for her because you look like
yeah I think he does have like blindly
loyal fans yeah that you know can argue
away a lot of this stuff and like he
does still have 13 million subscribers
like I don't
he has no like now relationships in the
YouTube space like everyone has
unfollowed him people he worked with
there was also bridges that he had
burned before like because people were
just actively waiting to unfold yes so
now it's like Jacqueline Hill who like
apparently they had a little bit of
because like James was mean to her like
yes she's gonna jump much she's excited
yeah I obviously like coming out of the
woodwork we've been burnt
yeah by James Charles I'm just I'm so
shocked by this that's all I'll say
shook about it I mean it really kept me
entertained her video like got me
through a 45-minute car ride and she's a
precious gem of a woman and I'm so sorry
now nobody to it like I want to know
more about her husband right he sounds
like rich and smart and yeah rich and
smart but definitely smart like yeah
negotiating contracts I can't I'll be
saying youtubers and then it just got
like gave you a window into like this
YouTube community
first of all why don't these people have
a reality show yeah totally and there's
just so much drama they're all like so
close and like hang out with each other
but also competition it's like such an
interesting dynamic that I never really
knew about no totally when she was like
I got James a deal like a competing deal
for a million dollars and a higher
percentage I was like what I need
friends like that no totally okay we'll
keep you posted on the story bhakti
Westbrook is the stunning example of no
good deed yeah well no because now she's
getting her comeuppance that's true
yeah justice has been served for Tati
and I'm sure like not only she getting
millions of subscribers but I'm sure
everyone's checking out halo bTW oh I
did yeah me too I just don't like
supplements like I don't think I need
them but I was just looking at it didn't
she also reference like that there was a
coordinated attack around her launch so
of course I had to look up halo Beauty
controversy yeah and there was all this
stuff that was coming out when she
launched her supplements that they were
like you know they could make
birth control less effective look if you
like all the supplements have side
effect like yeah it was just it was
weird and it was like so who launched
attack was it sugar bear hair right this
is run even deeper there's a weird it's
it's weird to go into the supplement
space because like with this moral
compass cuz it's like it's an like a
feat weird chemically like unethical
business I mean coming into the
supplement space was definitely weird
choice but I think she that like she was
so passionate about it really was that
she took on the wrist yeah I don't know
in the words of Lord Varys greater risk
greater reward
oh we will recap at the end I I can't
I'm speechless honestly I don't see in
the words of John and che speechless
second story another bit of justice
being served Victoria's Secret Fashion
Show says goodbye to network television
the Victoria's Secret Fashion Show an
annual spectacle of glitter cleavage and
pop music will no longer air on network
television after merely to date after a
nearly two decade the amounts who it was
made in a Friday memo to the chains
associates from Leslie Wexner and the
executive the chief executive of
Victoria's Secret parent company L
brands mister Wexner said that the
company had been taking a very fresh
look at every aspect of our business in
the past few months and noted that the
brand must evolve and change to grow
with that in mind we have decided to
rethink the traditional board Victoria's
Secret Fashion Show going forward we
don't believe network television is the
right fit so I know it's like never good
to you know ant on someone's grave right
or like you know just relish in the
failure of others but like I just love
this I think that Victoria's Secret
Fashion Show like I was I've been
watching it since I remember being in
high school and like taking pictures
like me eating cupcakes like huh and
like I just can't help but think how
detrimental that was to my mental health
and like my body image and I wonder what
it would have been like to have grown up
in a world without the Victoria's Secret
Fashion Show because I think I would
have been like a whole lot more
confident which is so scary to think
about so I'm just so excited because I
haven't watched in like two years it's
just like a knowing where like
everyone's watching something like
people who don't watch Game of Thrones
but like everyone else is watching it
and you're not yeah and also I just
think the brand and that show
specifically sends such a horrible
message and I'm so happy that it's no
longer gonna be greats in the
televisions of millions of Americans I
just can't believe like this has
happened so soon like last year the
rating
we're really bad but usually like they
drag something out until they let it die
um I'm so I'm so excited I'm so grateful
and like really when the show happens
live it's all over social media
everyone's posting about it talking
about it we're seeing clips and then it
airs a month later we have to go through
all of that again yeah so like the
social media aspect makes it live and I
think that that is more than enough of
your garbage you know yeah it's just so
weird because it really for a while was
like this majorly prestigious like
accomplishment as a model like if you
watching a show if you've got your angel
wings whatever but like I really feel
like Sports Illustrated has usurped that
and like last year before this was
canceled if you were a model would you
have rather been gotten your wings as a
name gel or been like one of the rookies
who like might be on the cover of Sports
Illustrated uh it depends I think that
being an angel is way more lucrative
financially I don't know that being on
the cover of Sports Illustrated pays
anything like from there you get
catapulted into stardom and you'll get
money from that but like Victoria's
Secret is as much as it's problematic
like a major moneymaker and I think they
pay their angels like millions of
dollars really so like it's a set for
life sort of thing yeah so it just
depends on what you're looking for
there's just so many models now who like
just what are they gonna do you know
yeah well they'll still be Victoria's
Secret Angels and like Victoria's
Secret's not like the business is
shutting but is there you're gonna
revolve around still the show but it's
just not on TV show will still happen
how lame is that I mean what's the point
of the show it's like any of the [__]
they wear is actually sold yeah but like
all fashion houses have shows runway
shows that don't air on TV so it's like
a money but it's like Victoria's Secret
it's not a fashion house they literally
sell underwear that would be like Haines
so but it's still gonna be like a
marketing tool for them but just not
done on it and they also kept saying
network television it's like maybe I'll
be on three yeah yeah oh definitely be
streaming it's gonna be on YouTube yeah
great cool like Coachella
that's where it deserves to be agreed
let it die there he met it died there
but it's still gonna happen and the
girls were angels are still angels and
they'll still be in the commercials and
I just think they'll be able to pull
such prestigious music talent like who
wants to be on a [__] live stream
Coachella yeah but like there's people
there too yeah yeah
I mean I think it'll be good but you
know it definitely needs to operate and
just like a smaller corner of the world
and not like everywhere you know who's
laughing to the bank ooh
third love editor I mean they're always
laughing to the bank in general but
they're especially laughing today and so
are we because they sponsor our show
yeah I mean we also our team very loud
like speaking of people who sponsor our
show check you Zola when you got married
I did I'm still using Zola to go through
all my registry stuff and it organizes
everything for me so when I'm setting my
thank-you notes like it makes it so
comprehensive oh look you like a
checklist yes okay well Zola is the
easiest way to plan your wedding and
register you can join five hundred
thousand couples oh my god who of you
Zola Zola takes the stress out of
wedding planning with free wedding
websites your dream wedding registry
affordable save the dates and
invitations and easy-to-use planning
tools you could start with a free
website it's so easy and takes just
minutes to set up you can choose from
over a hundred beautiful wedding
websites to choose from and they fit any
couple style and every type of wedding
and FAQ section helps address those
awkward questions like can I bring my
kids do I have a plus-one I just had a
situation like that where I got invited
without a plus-one and I'm like I'm
married but like it's a destination
wedding so I feel like they didn't know
that I was gonna be in town with my
husband whatever so to start your free
wedding website and also get $50 off
your registry go to Zola comm slash
toast once again to start your free
wedding website and also get $50 off
your registry on Zola go to Zola comm
slash toast
vol a premium spec premium is fact like
so helpful and takes you know a little
bit of the stress of wedding planning I
have the equation a little yes as much
as how much stress that you have right
our next story I don't know if you've
heard about the drama around Constance
whoo oh my god I didn't you know I'm
still glad we're talking about this
because I'm confused as ever and I was
so invested in this story but not
invested enough to read her statement
cuz the font was so small okay well I'll
read her statement but a little
backstory
it was announced last week that fresh
off the bone is going to be renewed for
another season and that I had literally
though I do sell a television I know and
Constance we tweeted quote so upset
right now that I'm literally crying and
she wrote [__] hell and it seemed
like it might be about the ABC show was
the time was the time and it was in high
it was about the ABC show so everyone
like why are you being ungrateful at
your show got renewed like you're not
think you're working actor blah blah
blah so on Saturday the actress posted a
lengthy meses message on Twitter titled
these words are my truth I hope you hear
them following her bizarre reaction to
fresh-off-the-boat being picked up for a
sixth season quote I was temporarily
temporarily upset yesterday not because
I hate the show but because its renewal
meant I had to give up another project
that I was really passionate about she
explained so Midas made social media
replies were more about that other
project not about fresh-off-the-boat
fresh off the boat is a great show that
I'm proud of and that I enjoy she said
mentioning that she knows her character
Jessica like the back of her hand and
playing her is fun easy and pleasant as
the actress has expressed in the past
she doubled down on the fact that she
enjoys taking on new projects quote that
other project would have challenged me
as an artist that other project would
have been really hard and not easy or
pleasant at all she said but admitted
that her tweets form following the
announcement of the show's renewal was
bad timing and quote insensitive to
those who are struggling I know it's a
huge privilege that I even have options
options that fresh-off-the-boat
afforded me she said noting with the
show and blockbuster film crazy rich
Asians under her belt she was poised to
take on roles that are quote unfamiliar
and scary
concluding her message she said she
hoped fans believed she enjoys working
on pressure off the boat but explained
that she's also allowed to be
disappointed by the fact that she lost
out on another acting exciting game
quote I appreciate those who have given
me the space and faith to believe what I
say about both parts of my heart it's
meaningful when you make the choice to
believe women oh my god
yeah she pulled Taylor Swift okay and
this is like the most upsetting story
because I think I addressed everything
before the belief women yes that's an
that's a whole another beast
I love Constance true love but this is
prime example of just like the Hollywood
like entitlement and hypocrisy that we
see it's like and then once I saw this
empty was like going in on her on
Twitter that like she has she's like a
James Charles like she's out of control
ever since this movie that's what he
said and like now I'm like kind of
seeing that this statement is so wild
like first of all this is something like
she's totally allowed to be upset I get
that it's like this show got you rate
rose you to the place that you're are
now and like you feel like you've
outgrown it and I totally get that
and it does suck if there's this other
project that you want to do but like
don't tweet it [__] right looks so
ungrateful and like literally they're
people
like would die for the opportunity to be
on that show like as an extra and you're
the star of it and you're not okay with
it like so done like be a little
self-aware and like don't post that
right I understand the way that she felt
but the fact that she thought even for a
second like to tweet about it it just
shows how out of touch she is because
she didn't even think of what that looks
like to other people out of touch you
said it sister so also I mean there's
when I love a show there's nothing I
hate more than knowing that the people
who are on the show don't want to be
there so like let's share it in
Desperate Housewives right Nicollette
Sheridan dynasty Richard was it like
Gossip Girl The OC Marissa Cooper yeah
so as a fan of fresh off the boat like I
would be really disappointed and upset
like to know this so I mean I haven't
read what empties been saying but that
makes a lot of sense because only
someone who's out of control and out of
touch could even like things that it's
okay to to publicly say something like
this no I definitely feel how everyone
we're all selfish we all want that for
ourselves right and I get that look I
can't say that if I was in the same
situation like I wouldn't want to take
on the Bayer Project to leave my little
show behind but I would never be stupid
enough to put it on Twitter because
Twitter is the darkest place in the
world and only you're only gonna come
off as entitled and spoiled and really
like not self-aware and like absolutely
nothing positive could have come out of
her tweeting that so like what did she
think was gonna happen like I understand
sometimes like I feel like ariana grande
does it all the time she tweets and
deletes all the time but it's because
that she needed to say something that
the world needed to understand but it's
like it's it wasn't socially like she
just didn't want it out there yeah but
this is like and there are so many
positives to her doing that because we
get to see a glimpse of something and by
the way it was like tweet it was a
tirade of like really weird tweets with
the word [__] it yeah no no and
there's just nothing positive that could
have come out from this and like even if
she needed an outlet like text a friend
call a phone a friend no totally but now
let's talk about the end of this the end
the statement which is I'm gonna read it
once more because it's that shocking and
I'll go slower this time I appreciate
those who have given me the space and
faith to believe what I say about both
parts of my heart it's meaningful when
you make the choice to believe women so
not only do I not understand it I'm put
off by it so what I'm not understanding
is she's grateful for the whatever yeah
yeah
and then two parts of her heart what are
the two parts the two different projects
took about a four yeah like that she
wants one thing but she wants another
thing so like that half of the sentence
makes sense like that you can understand
please understand that there are two
parts my heart you know the heart wants
what it wants but then the second half
of making the choice to believe women
makes no goddamn sense and it's like
just such a don't don't
such a lazy remark no don't it's an
offensive remark
let me try get this stupid sentence out
don't don't
oh man I'm having that ham don't use
that phrase superfluously because then
it loses its meaning and then any time
someone says don't believe believe women
it'll be a joke like when Taylor Swift
were like women supporting other women
now it's a joke okay but like and also
what does she want me to believe exactly
that that she didn't mean what she said
and that she just wanted to do something
a challenger artistically okay yeah does
it make sense why should we believe you
just cuz you're a woman no but like I
believe you like it didn't need
convincing
like I just I just think you're a [__]
now but I believe it yeah totally wait
the plot thickens because I saw on the
panel of the page six Jemma Chan
clarifies like tweet that criticized
constant Woo's TV show drama Jemma Chan
who was also in crazy rich Asians asked
her the most beautiful woman alive
apparently like to tweet that has since
been deleted it said three constant
whose conduct today comes as no surprise
to anyone who has worked with her in
recent years she has a reputation for
being rude petty mean-spirited and
ungrateful many people on social media
took Chan's like of that tweet to mean
that she agreed with it indicating that
there was a feud between her and woo
over the weekend however she tweeted
that the like was simply an accident
just to clarify it was an accidental
like anyone looking for drama or beef
sorry to disappoint
oh my god no it totally wasn't and like
I trust Jemma Chan you know Damien I
trust you have a tan but also like wait
this is so crazy it also means that she
was like something for what yeah of
course
it's so embarrassing she should have a
dresser yeah nobody but if consciousness
like so scary like no Constance is so
scary
this is such a shock no I'm totally
bleeding on teh like she's a nightmare I
mean that was so surprising like one
like shoot you're working as an actor
like on fresh off the boat like you have
a career but like literally nobody knows
who you are and then one stupid rom-com
and you're invited to the Oscars like of
course wouldn't you get a big head yeah
and she's nominated for Golden Globe
right she's turning into Katherine Heigl
yeah yeah that's exactly what the
comparison that you were making
comparisons but also the bonuses sake
how many me see it's going into his
sixth season like it's very successful
and those are the things that pay like
that pay so it wasn't like she was not a
working actress and she got crazier she
just catapulted to fame it's like she
has had a string of like great success
this is so ungrateful oh my god that
makes me so mad like uh I just want to
get to a place this is my goal obviously
I want to become rich and famous doing
whatever it is that makes me money but I
also want to become like powerful I like
a powerful force in Hollywood that like
if there is a Constance we want him ever
on set with her like I can literally
whip her into shape and two seconds are
you [__] kidding me yeah and now
she's also in the movie with that that
hustler movie that they just filmed with
JLo and carnelian where she is what is
she complaining about
I don't know and now I have to know what
this other secret project was yeah and I
don't know if we'll ever find out she
launching presents Jackie O flow to our
Tokyo calm if you just want to get your
answer going on point vibrant fun
colorful just like mine wow this is so
wild so I love Gemma I believe her like
I just trust her yeah and we have to
believe women right therefore I choose
to believe Gemma job but then you also
have to believe that it was an accident
oh that's true here's the thing that was
such I can reconcile it I believe that
it was an accident but she was trolling
Constance we hate tweets it tells me
everything I need to know totally it's
like I would never if like even in any
sort of situation where I'm like reading
tweets about people like I would never
get involved I just like like to read
another to read once and I'm like if it
was your coworker yeah right if it was
like yeah but we're also sisters so it's
like you should read everything about me
but it was like a distant coworker near
just there sipping the tea reading all
the hate tweets like you're it's that's
not your friend no but I don't think
Jemma Chad ever claimed to be Constance
to his best friend no but like she
claims that they have no beef right
that's true this isn't a beefless
situation okay fourth story very sad
Real Housewives of Miami star Elsa
Patton
elsa dies at the age of 84 after a long
illness Elsa Patton was known to Real
Housewives of Miami viewers as mama Elsa
oh my god so sad but she lived a good
life and I feel like she got famous at
the end of it which is all you can
really hope for and I just know that my
mouth is in a better place I just feel
like Marysol is like not gonna be okay
no but I feel as though mamma else has
been not well for a long time because
every time something like even when we
had Lisa Hochstein on the show a long
time ago she said like mama Elsa wasn't
doing okay and like you know every time
we came up on watching up inside it was
like she was sick and so at least she's
at peace now right and like when that
happens you do get the opportunity to
like reconcile with the death and say
goodbye and like move on even before the
person passed that's like what they were
singing Real Housewives in New York like
people think it's weird that Jill Zarin
moved on so quickly but it's like Bobby
was so sick for so long like it gives
you like the time exposure like move on
even if the person's still there right
and you get closure you don't have all
these unanswered questions that you have
to like go on a journey to find out who
you know much like Bethenny right right
so matter so released the same in quote
our beloved Elsa Patton passed away over
Mother's Day weekend after a long
illness she was surrounded by her family
and very close friends the family is so
very grateful to the many fans and
friends who have continued to ask for
her and offer their prayers and best
wishes yeah I feel like everyone's
always asking how hot does Miami was
extremely divisive like there were
people on all sides of the of the show
but I feel like everyone pretty much
respected and unified for a mom Elsa
yeah they all rallied around her and I
hope she's resting in peace me too and
for that I appreciate her and I I miss
her and I wishing myself out in the best
right and maybe like this an excuse to
bring that Real Housewives of Miami
always though I love you know that one
was really gone too soon
uh-huh okay fifth and final story
because I just have to get to Game of
Thrones okay pertinent the best and
worst airlines and airports of 2019 has
been released the seventh annual study
by air help reveals passenger pinch
points and expanding travel market I
found this study to be most interesting
because you know what the number one
worst airport in America is LaGuardia no
worse let me think
JFK nope Newark yes believe it
Newark it's the worst luckily I'm going
there today and more than that it's like
the propaganda that United Airlines has
been pushing out around the city about
Newark like it's 30 mil boards
everywhere there's cabs with live clocks
on them they're obviously fake though
where you could be on the easternmost
side of the city and say it's 40 minutes
to Newark and it's 50 minutes to JFK
that makes no goddamn sense and they've
this new campaign because the Newark
like you know how every Airport has like
the three dit letter like code its ewr
so they even like a new like ad campaign
where it's like it's newer like it's a
newer it's like it's oldest Jake it's
crusty it's [__] Airport don't give
me that pill [__] United it's
[__] terrible like oh my god if we
went there when we went to Coachella and
like oh yes astonished because I have
been there like two years ago but now
you see all these campaigns around the
city that make you think that it's JFK
LaGuardia Newark it's just the trifecta
of New York airports and no it's not
it's JFK and LaGuardia but you know what
with JFK it's like I hate ufk because
it's the biggest airport on the planet
it's like they'll drop you at a gate
that dead-ass is almost a mile from like
the curb and it's torture but at least
it's like tortured with Shake Shack and
clean bathrooms and non-self carts like
it's a bustling metropolis is that
without the new so it's like I just
looked at my boarding pass for this
morning and you know where I'm going I'm
going to gate c 138 how far does that
sound that sounds so far with no golf
carts no shake check and no restaurant
bustling metropolis no nothing makes
sense at Newark like you check-in on one
floor and then you have to like wait on
the stairs for security and like they
make you go through like a maze like a
hamster to get to security because by
the time you get there yeah there's no
line because you spent 40 minutes
walking so the weight is 40 minutes but
they advertise it like the weight is
zero minutes do they say what the best
airport was oh yes I will get to another
ten [__] on you and then this was
like so irresponsible I thought you know
how they have those new bins where you
even have to put your like your carrot
your luggage your oh and then push it
and then it's like you can't get in
because the other ones rolling up it's
so stupid so I had all my things and I
put my laptop of my iPad in the separate
bin and the guy who was moving them all
around separated myself so he literally
left mine while my stuff was going
through my laptops and my things were
still at the other end of
the of the trolley trolley and they tell
you that you can't like not be with your
personal items so I'm like sir can you
please put it with just put it on not
eating them with are some items just
like moving I can't not be with my atoms
but I can't be in two places that one do
I get a terrible ABI no I get terrible
anxiety like when my items go through
and like I'm stuck waiting for the
scanner or opposite like when I get
separated from my items and they're no
longer in my line of vision oh great my
stuff is being stolen I walk around with
like the most obnoxious Louie Vuitton
suitcase I'm like they're totally gonna
steal for me it's not even their fault
if like they can't get it all to match
up perfectly but the least you could do
is keep my [__] together so it's not
like impossible for my things like for
me to be with my things
no it's like the TSA is constantly
evolving with like these new
technologies and like whatever but it's
only making it worse like there is this
door I love LaGuardia Airport there is
this door Jackie like oh my god I cannot
it makes me I'm raped okay ready
so it's way it's when you're leaving the
airport so you're like about to be at
the curb and there's like these double
doors or automatic doors that open
there's two sets it's so [__] stupid
okay there's two sets of automatic like
opening doors you walk through the first
set and the second one won't open you're
like stuck in this blast box
yeah it's not until everyone comes into
the box the door first set of door
closes that the second set of doors can
open for crowd control oh I want a giant
like stuck in a box with these smelly
strangers it would just out of play-doh
like give me the [__] out of here no I'm
gonna need someone to explain that one
to me no truly I literally like I get
mad like excuse me what's this one I'm
like I'm not going in here it's scary
it's like a little BOTS it's crowd
control what now there's there's nobody
ever at LaGuardia what's crowd control
I'm like in this stupid box by myself
and then like opened door I'm like US
airports in general didn't fare
particularly well with the highest-rated
u.s. airport being hartsfield-jackson
Atlanta International Airport I have
been there so it's the number one
Airport in America and it was range
number 34 in the world Wow I mean Margot
got massages they're like it's legit oh
yeah we did we got two massages there
why not like the nail place over the
that like we're chair that you like hum
you know and then they have a full spa
like me and Marta went in and like
no like a different one in the Delta Sky
Lounge oh that's nice a major reason why
apparently US airports suck is because
of weather delays but a delay does it
make me hate an airport and only it
makes me anything but um that's not
that's not expand its Chiefs you know
it's so funny is when we talk a lot we
say but um it sound like but um but I'm
yeah if you have the slightest amount of
snow at JFK the airport will close so to
make me hate the airport you know but
it's like that
LaGuardia when women when we got stuck
in the divine diversion if we'd been
going somewhere else I'm with a normal
Airport we might have been able to lend
but it's like the air traffic control at
LaGuardia and JFK and New Yorkers like
such a Messick than New York air traffic
control I can't get their [__] together
know it also because it was in November
and they hadn't made the arrangements
for like winter yet think like they did
a nice winter was coming and they didn't
know what to do when they she's just
watching it with roads right um but the
number one Airport in the world is
Doha's Hamad International Airport Tokyo
and neat oh those are top three what's
Doha the bug I don't know let's look it
up look what town Doha what city I got
to go there it sounds Middle Eastern
yeah in Qatar see and then the next one
is in Tokyo and we wish honestly I just
wish that Newark would get a [__]
together okay Newark had [__] together a
new record [__] together a new workout
it [__] together Newark added [__]
together Newark get it together second
one it's Tokyo and 30s Athens
International Airport
I guess so I'm gonna assume cool let me
just make sure well I'm going to
ben-gurion airport which is their port
in Tel Aviv Israel
that's a nice Airport - yes and there's
a kosher McDonald's so like I'm gonna be
in heaven
oooh I was thinking last night me and
Ben like me man first of all since we've
been married haven't been to Israel
together cuz it's not even since we've
been married since we've been together
thanks crazy since we've been together
for the last five years we've been two
cantos are like three times but as a
family like just girls so I haven't been
to his row but then and I was just
thinking last night in bed like
literally fell asleep dreaming up like
all the food I was getting it well you
can do just like so much meat like I'm
literally gonna have a filet mignon at
every meal I'm jealous
and I'm like hopping on to TP G's
itinerary for like half the trip and
he's going to this coastal chef
so he's like this famous Israeli chef in
named Murray boarding and he's an AW Co
Israel like on the coast and like we're
getting like a private experience and
it's like we're just gonna go to like
fish market with him like pick out well
you want me but he's gonna cook up
this restaurant like when I tell my
friends about it they're like you're
going to worry I don't know how I'm
gonna say is it like I'm gonna talk to
him without being like what do you boo T
but I'm just like I'm just so excited to
eat like that's what I'm going to like t
BG is doing all like it's his first time
so like he's doing like Masada the JED
see it's like once you've done that once
I can't it's the drives are like four
hours too hot I'm going to the beach
and I want to go buy art and eat a lot
and like that's the type of trip on try
to have that's so nice and so fun oh and
while you're gone it's gonna be a smash
on the toast week so she is co-hosting
with me on Tuesday Wednesday and Friday
and Friday we have country star mitchell
Tenpenny i'm like right and then you
guys are under the call sign a ship him
and cinch Jack I think it's a girlfriend
who we met oh oh and then it's nature's
going to the concert plans oh but the
Old Dominion Mitchell time had concert
at MSG and then Thursday's episode will
be alive from Israel podcast with oh
really
yeah the venue and whomever you choose
will have to figure out the timing it's
actually better for you because you're
ahead
so you could record it at like 3 o'clock
is a real time and it goes up at before
we're great I just check my itinerary
Thursday yeah sure take your time
I think Thursday's today that Ben and I
yeah we're gonna do some so I'll do it
then perfect
um so yeah that'll be fine Game of
Thrones holy [__] if you have much this
is time to turn off by go to tokyo flow
calm and get my presets purchase a
premium Instagram experience for the
rest of your life and then watch my
youtube video on how to actually
implement set presets and then go to
grow [__] dark on get tickets to the
tour so you can take pictures of the
tour and use the presets exactly it was
such a great episode what I don't like
about Game of Thrones is when they do
like one battle for the whole episode
it's like so harrowing it's like you're
in the battle and it's like we just let
the battle and but that's the only time
when things happen right everyone's been
complaining all season that nothing's
happening taking plant but I also forgot
about the first part of the episode
which was insane like I love
lore virus justice for lord beerus and
the whole world like was turned upside
down because like what you think you
know you no longer know it's like Tyrion
to me was like the good and the
righteous and like the moral compass and
like he was always just like doing what
he felt was right
and he [__] snitch and got Lord Varys
killed in the most inhumane way ever and
I was so disappointed by him well the
red woman says that death by fire is the
purest death but it's also the most
painful yeah but he needed scream well
so okay I've never watched your episode
with Ben
before I didn't realize that cuz been
I've been walking since the beginning
well yes I've been watching since the
beginning and been used to not watch so
this is the first season that we're both
on but I've been gone every single
Sunday so I was like oh wonder what it's
like to watch it then it's so annoying
ready you're gonna die okay he comes up
with the worst theories and he said no
look I'm like okay and this was his
theory ready you're gonna it's to the
dumbest theory when Lord vadas got
CHIKARA's but I was like oh my god he's
not gonna burn that's a [__] terrible
call but Danica's he didn't fall to his
knees immediately like he kind of stood
up and got burned look he's up he's up
he's he's judging I'm like first of all
that's the worst well second of all it's
not true third of all stop [__]
talking oh my god that's the worst if I
can cause that was so annoying he's just
like I don't know why he didn't scream
it's just cuz he's just like so poised
but that like the moment where he like
but I just want to know did he get at
least one Radin out I think so I think
so too I think so because you see him
writing the letter who the hell is he
sitting into everyone's jet engines let
it I know but like maybe um I was
singing about it cuz everyone said in
concerning also everyone all of the High
Lords are dead but a few weeks ago they
reference the new Prince of Dorne
everybody yeah um Oberyn died ever since
Oberyn and O and thus ancestors were
taken um so maybe like people like that
like you know young hot things coming up
in the world yeah they'll be crazy well
and maybe even like Gendry who's now the
new king of storms end yeah I mean last
name was such a wild episode it's so
frustrating for so many reasons like one
you convinced me last week that Jaime
Lannister was tricking us I have a Megan
and he was totally not me he's totally
at [__] snitch no he's a [__]
[__] okay he's a [__] but like who
would have thought that in this whole
show that Jaime and Cersei would be the
great love story of Game of Thrones not
only that like that I would kind of be
sympathetic toward them at the end I was
like honestly I hope they get out and
get to the boat and just like go start a
new life yeah with their baby no I
didn't hope that they got out cuz I
needed Cersei to get what she deserved
and by the way she didn't know no death
was not lovely it was lovely
she got she came into the world with
Jaime and she gets to leave the world
with Jaime and their bet like what a
poetic beautiful like who wants to live
in this new world and right when the
Hound just like let Cersei walk by was a
killer and Arya a big joke came all this
way just accomplished something the
second she gets there she decides she
doesn't
now she might die because she was a big
joke but she would have died if she
stayed there but at least she would have
gotten to kill Cersei yeah but like we
need her alive to kill Daenerys who by
the way Arya will be killing because a
person has green eyes yeah okay so
Daenerys Targaryen lost her goddamn mind
and it's like I was rooting for you we
were all rooting for you but you know
what I woke up this morning and somehow
through the toasters I found myself on a
reddit thread called queen of the ashes
where it shows how when this person has
been watching that Game of Thrones and
it shows how literally in every season
since season 1 it has been foreshadowing
that she was gonna burn the city to the
ground
and so her madness they didn't try and
shove her madness into the past three
episodes and explain how she went mad
like she has always been quick to turn
to violence
it's only been Jorah and her advisers
who have been able to stop her anytime
something happens her her initial
reaction is to kill them I'll kill the
Masters burn them all we're gonna you
know we're gonna burn this city to the
ground
I mean cars won't let me you know
capitally um that's true
there's definitely like a foreshadowing
of her being violet but she like when
she was in slavers Bay and marine like
she was always really concerned about
like the common people like freeing the
slaves and I think there was this like
empathy for people that is completely
devoid now like she doesn't give a [__]
about anyone but herself yeah I think
she like had a tyrannic militaristic
approach to being an empathetic ruler
it's like she will do whatever it takes
humane or inhumane to become a humane
ruler but like that's not humane no not
at all and I mean I didn't she she's so
nuts and obviously could have been
handled so much better like they rang
the bell she could have taken Cersei as
a prisoner and done whatever she wanted
she was not the Wildfire for a second
yes so was that the one that was stored
beneath the red keep that was just like
getting exploded because of the fires
yes so when the Mad King was going mad
he had all of these possible fire stored
in the city center so there was one
under the Sept of Baelor and Cersei knew
about it that's why she blew it up but
there were still six more in the most
targeted areas where people would die
the most people would die and they never
removed and so when the city was burning
it triggered all those wildfires and
literally the whole city went up in
flames she did like her daddy said she
burned them all no
first of all she's trimming into her dad
all right she knows she's out of control
she's worse than her dad ever Chucky
she's Cersei she's worse than Cersei
she's more evil than Cersei he's Cersei
never had to kill that many people no
and let's used to her she was just like
a selfish [__] who wants to sit on the
throne that she had absolutely no right
to she didn't give a [__] about the
people around her she wouldn't have
killed them because she didn't care
enough about them yes like Daenerys is
this hate up for the people of King's
Landing she's never at them no and like
honestly I had a hate for the people of
King's Landing too because they were all
the people who were cheering when Ned
Stark died they've always just been a
horrible people you know throwing
science in the alley but I always like
raping each other and [__] on the
ground but like when you're on the
ground and King's Landing and they are
so rendering yeah it's over yeah and
it's like the unsullied are like two
loyal to Daenerys so it's like she kept
firing so they kept even though there's
sorts out of yeah the unsullied just
Dany is their queen and they're guarding
and I don't understand that for them
because she freed them so yeah that's
your but John and Tyrion both had like a
come to Jesus moment like two hours too
late in last night's episode when she
like wouldn't stop and they were like
pull back and if John made it out alive
which we don't know but like he probably
dead yeah he's him and Tyrion have got
to team up and and get together but
honestly like I [__] hate Tyrion
except that scene when he freed Jaime he
was like you were the only one who never
treated me like a monster like I
actually was crying those says that I
was talking but I understood Tyrion
because I'm like I feel like Terry's a
relatable guy like he's not superhuman
in the fact that he's smart like you
know he he's always tried to do the
right thing and at a certain point he
had to make a decision of who to trust
and like if I were him I would have
continued to trust Danny too because
like that's we'd seen so much good in
her you know and like he didn't want to
give up on that and but when she when
like even right before she burned the
city down like I still thought she was
good I still thought was with Terry and
like I was still giving her the benefit
of the doubt
she said she wouldn't burn the city when
when the bells rang right and she didn't
and what's most frustrating is that if
this was always gonna be the way that
she took King's Landing they could have
took it months ago that's the thing she
didn't really even need the unsullied or
the Dothraki or the northern army just
fly up there with these stupid it's like
oh you never they were so you were
terrible at flying your dragon up until
yesterday because like you were getting
to all these ridings kill the Consul
getting shot down no but like the
Dragons who got killed they weren't
manned by her
so like it was actually better that she
didn't have stray dragons that they
could like the dragons are you know
there's still animals like they don't
know what that like they're gonna duck
but not like she can see she can think
like a human being so if she only really
needed one dragon and no so where was
all this firepower when you were
fighting the white walkers ya know it's
like what they did to Kings letting I
was singing I'm like you should just sit
on the wall and did that the whole time
yeah it was really I mean it's it's
terrible well so now I don't understand
like everyone is somehow convinced that
sounds it takes Iron Throne which I just
think is a bad idea and I don't think
it's true but how does Sansa now fit in
like because okay so now it's really
like everyone it's Arya John terian
against Danny like Danny is it tyrant
and nobody wants her so let's say they
overthrow her John is the rightful heir
so like how does Thompson fit it sound
says is leave when the north ya know but
people are convinced she's gonna take
the Iron Throne
oh no cuz then that would leave the
North open Arya doesn't want it bran
doesn't want it it has to be Sansa and
if Arya now like values her life because
she had a near-death experience she
better go find Gendry and become the
Lady of that little town ya know it has
to be sons in the north and I think John
on the throne is the only way to bring
the north back into the fold right and
then it's like the Starks truly rule the
world which is like would be such a
great way to end this which is also like
at 18 years ago and Ned Stark just sad
his badass kind of avoided all of this
yeah and it's like everyone so quickly
like sets aside for Sansa
but never forget 90 not lady yeah like
so much of what happened in the last
eight seas in a sense ounces fault for
being a dumb entitled [__] as an
eleven-year-old and as much as children
make mistakes for sure but let me not
forget she's still she's making up for
it now sure just like Seon did but like
I wouldn't put C on on the Iron Throne
definitely not I'm like just because
Danny went mad doesn't mean Sansa was
right no not at all and by the way that
wasn't even sound to saying not like
Danny's a mad woman it's not like she
was she was prideful to write you know
what nobody really understood that
Daenerys was going that except for
Cerberus he called it and they got
killed for it yeah and he knew she was
going mad because she wasn't eating and
it's like just be like yes you're number
one confidant has died but like you
can't lose your mind no this is what I
was explaining to Ben because I was
arguing with him but I'm like she's so
emotional it's like Jon would be an
amazing leader john has lost his real
dad his real mom his fake dad
take mom his brother his brother's wife
his brother's baby like Silva knee and
he still keeps it together it's not
crying and yet morning all the time it's
like sorry too nervous you want to be a
leader you want to be a warrior people
die and his best friends yeah
also beerus could have been saying
anyone - Samwell Tarly who is now the
lord of his house yeah oh yeah yeah I'm
already knew oh right but it's Samwell
Tarly Gendry the new Prince of Dorne who
are like gonna be the new heads of home
and maybe like in the middle of a battle
they're gonna like show up like status
did that one time yeah but now my
question is like even if Arya kills Dany
like the unsullied will they will ride
for her they're right or die but their
pride for a dead person no but like they
won't get like how well does that work
how will they convince the armies that
Danny's not the Queen because that's all
they've ever known oh that's so said
they're gonna have to die too
there'd be no people left right well
last night when like everyone was dying
and I thought for sure
Arya John we're both gonna die like I'm
thinking I thought in the beginning of
the season that the end result was
everyone's gonna die from the White
Walkers well like maybe everyone just
dies from each other and it's like a
message about warfare perhaps I never
definitely make a statement like in what
however they choose to end it it's gonna
be a political statement like yeah in
this tough economic climate yeah I never
thought Arya or John we're gonna die
because like John has to sit on the
throne but like what throne there's no
people no and she literally burned the
throne Jen but I guess there are still
seven other kingdoms what are they gonna
make the actual throne I'm talking about
like where is it it's a said it's there
but she burned down the red cape
she burned em part parts of it she
thinks she kept that one that one
building how did she know was there also
that that um it won't melt I don't think
it it melts it's made of Valyrian steel
yeah but like it'll just get all banged
up amongst the rubble and I'll get a
little more irony and it's like just
King's Landing is now ashes like how do
they rebuild a city it's like they don't
even have like drills no it's like she
was giving herself so much work like
making it so like she has to take on all
these finances now like to rebuild the
city and why would she do that to
herself I was just and I love I mean
it's crazy how once she's on the dragon
she hears the bells ring and then she
makes the decision to be a monster and
we never see her again like she's
somewhere being a crazy she's gone mad
she's gotten eight
it was horrible I mean we always knew it
wasn't gonna have a happy ending they've
literally told us that over and over
again um but I just I can't believe like
I've like I just I rode hard for Danny
no you did up until the very last minute
like I dropped her at the beginning of
the season I was done with that I wrote
hard for up even in last episode that
she's allowed to have be human and have
emotions in it I think so many people
are so disappointed that like you know
this person that we've loved and has
like had so many positive like character
development over the past eight seasons
like in just one episode it's like all
of that is gone
I only feel that way about Jamie that's
silly to me I don't feel that way about
Daenerys I think they've tried to tell
us so many times like well she has magic
in her I mean and and it will take us
like yeah we always knew she had the
madness you know like she's a Targaryen
but like there has to be a switch
flipped it's kind of like three
identical strangers when they were like
it has to be activated yes and he was
active II I know I'm not gonna say that
I called that she was gonna go crazy but
I have been really watching and what
I've noticed is not that she's crazy is
that she was never really a good leader
and she was like every time she wanted
to do something she was convinced
otherwise by the people around her and
it's like she also just like got this
army got the Marine got all the stuff
like cuz of her dragons like she never
earned anything she just like showed up
places and expected people to give her
everything and surrender when like she
was just some [__] you know yeah I yeah
that in certain in certain instances
like she just like played the dragon she
needs a new advisor she needs like set
up a website on Squarespace because
she's now hiring for fresh advisors who
aren't [__] crazy she'll call it
Danny's waiters dot-com no more like
need new Jorah com it must replace Jorah
calm well if you want to start a website
much like Daenerys has got to
Squarespace is all in one its domains
its web sites for your online stores
marketing tools from websites and online
stores to marketing tools and analytics
Squarespace is the all-in-one platform
to build a beautiful online presence and
run your business like Jackie did new
feature they have email campaigns you
can say more you've been somewhere
you've consistent content from your
website to your email you can turn your
cool idea into a new website showcase to
work publish blog content sell products
or services of all kinds promote your
physical or online business and you can
own your own tummy and they've helped us
turn around we're so working on it our
Kim toast com website you know oh no oh
if you are can close campers
exciting news to make stay tuned on your
emails okay well before that head to
squarespace.com slash toast for a free
trial and when you're ready to launch
use the offer code toast to save 10% off
your first purchase of a website or
domain that's squarespace.com slash
toast for the free trial and then code
toast for 10% off of your first purchase
of a website or a domain correct
go for it go forth and prosper I love
Squarespace so yes nothing else really
happened
I think I was really you know that we
haven't recapped already but also just
like something highly unrealistic I
wanted to highlight one other thing that
happened was when John like turned Danny
down and like well no longer be boning
his hands knee chest I think that's the
right decision but I think between that
miss and a very strange aura and just
like you know the lack of sex from her
man like she she went crazy
but I just want to talk about how
unrealistic give us at Aria like his
lost in the city rubble like running
around and she runs into the same person
twice yeah okay and also like everyone
around her died that she lived I only
thought she was really gonna die when
Clegane was a looks like about to die
and they kept going back and forth
between those two scenes I was like oh
they're both gonna die yeah but I don't
think that's how she would die by like a
random break to the head no nothing that
like a trembling
yes Tempe yeah it's crazy I can't in the
shunt and it was it was just it was
shocking but and when they started the
battle and like they were on fire
literally like they everything was going
their way and yeah all the odds were
stacked against them like a [__] the
golden company a bunch of [__] oh my
god and that guy was hot though yes say
me faster Yeah right um no no cuz you
know why I thought it was first I good
yeah the guy Gianaris this guy from
Nashville Oh
Daario naharis I thought it was Madonna
and he also did start as this SSL sort
in the golden company it looked exactly
like he looks like OG Daario and that's
who they should have gotten to play
Daario 2.0 yes yes um everything was
going there by and like she it was just
I mean it was too good to be true but
the way that they took the city and no
one's ever taken King's Landing before
it was just like it was perfection and
and no way I'm not like impressed that
she took took Kings I think she burned
it down but before she burned it down
while she was standing on the dragon
deciding whether or not to go mad and
then this Giudice the Giudice which
flipped yeah everything she burned
scorpions they burn down the city wall
the armies coming through the innocent
people are tucked away in their homes
everything's going well in searcy you
know feels the pressure I just can't
tell you how excited I am that that guy
died her stupid maester fake baster cuz
he got kicked out of the Citadel well
yeah he was the worst oh and he was
poetic justice that he was killed by the
monster that he created yes and let's
talk about that mountain because when
they took his shirt off I was like shift
to the quarry
yeah he's basically like he was dead
like he was a
he's like Frankenstein I literally
thought he was a white Walker like he
like he wouldn't die you know he was
like pumped full of chemicals they kept
him alive but he didn't have like blood
running through his veins right and you
saw that actually when he was sorta no
when you go back to that season where
Meister what's his name hey freak
is that pice no pycelle is the old old
one yeah is like kind of doing dialysis
on him like he put he's taking all of
his blood out and I guess putting him
with you know chemist eel yeah steel no
that was that was great they both died
justice for the hound but you need to
die the way that he wanted to kill his
mother and I watched the inside the
episode after with the creator's who
everyone is blaming for everything yeah
and the Hound did have to have a death
by fire and it was like his hatred of
the mountain was the only thing stronger
than his fear of fire and so like that's
why that is poetic yeah I forgot I mean
he technically died like from all this
stuff leading up to the fire but he
ended the death in the fire yeah the
fire is what ultimately killed him if
before it even the fault yeah
interesting yeah but he wasn't afraid of
the fire cuz he was just so focused on
killing his brother but he always knew
that that was his you know purpose and
he got caught up in revenge which is why
when he like you know releases Arya from
her revenge filled hate it's like he had
this come to Jesus moment it's like you
have this decision now to spend your
life being like a hateful person just
seeking revenge then you get it and
it'll kill you or you can like you know
go back to what I felt done this guy
Gon's be bygones well it was really a
great episode I can't believe next
because the season finale I'm gonna be
on the plane home from Israel so like I
have to figure that out
oh [__] I mean well it's not that bad
you'll watch when you got home and you
just have to pull like a stagecoach and
not look at your coming I figured maybe
I can watch it on the plane but I just
have to figure out how not to be on now
HBO now but I just have to figure out
like this the Wi-Fi streaming situation
like ll which I'm not
oh no I'm flying L on the way home got
to wait to watch Lu at home and you just
can't be on your phone like but well
some I've been doing the plane there's
no Wi-Fi
oh yeah Church yeah just download some
movies you get home and you watch ok it
can be done we've done it a few times
now and it's the worst thing it's
torture yeah like not being able to be
on your phone and not being able to
engage with society I can't believe next
week is the last episode like I don't
want to watch it because I don't want it
to be over
I know if I never watch last episode it
never ends but I need you know what
happens with Danny oh my god [__]
nutjob
I can't we I was rooting for you we were
all rooting for you love you guys that's
all we got for you thank you for tuning
into the morning toast tomorrow starts
off snitch week here at TMT I will be in
Israel at the points guys so be sure to
follow me along on Instagram stories
Instagram posting it's gonna be premium
as [__] and I will be using my Jackie O
presets probably more the outdoor pack
beats they plan on spending a lot of
time outside I'm so excited to see what
you do with it Jackie O Flo calm to get
your presets two packs each are five for
twenty five that's five dollars a preset
which is very very fair I believe and
it's premium premium content know that
your flow looking vibrant if you're into
that sort of thing and not like those
you know grainy orangey gray gray
blogger presets that you usually see out
there I haven't seen any presets like
mine and I just love them so much and I
think that you will too I also have a
youtube tutorial up go to my instrument
orys that's the last circle thing for
all of that jazz also if you are a camp
toast camper we have a lot of fun
announcements this week to get you ready
for camp toast check your email check
the cam toes to group because it's going
down in the club it's going down by
you